we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here is a voicemail from again someone
who completely misunderstood everything
i've said
i just i i must really be a terrible
communicator let's listen
whoa david i really feel bad for you
right there when you describe the
options that you're exploring that last
one with poland and belarus that sounds
like the long shot
of the three
um how have you considered a fourth
option
maybe somewhere in spain or italy oh god
since you're fluent in spanish
i know there's spanish speakers in italy
uh
why not spain or italy have you thought
about that
i never said that moving to poland or
belarus is anywhere on my list when
someone said david what's your escape
plan if the u.s becomes authoritarian i
explained
because i was born in argentina i can go
back to argentina time that's an option
i could go to israel and i believe it's
within about a year i could get
citizenship there
the third option i mentioned is because
i have lineage to poland family that
fled poland before the holocaust there
is a law
which if you can prove that lineage
you can get a european passport okay i
explained the part of poland my family
was from is now belarus so
i'm not thinking of moving to belarus or
poland i was explaining that the
documents i need might be in what is now
belarus or they might be in what is now
poland but the point would be just to
get the european passport and with that
i would have my pick and and yes of
course i would probably end up either in
spain because i speak spanish
in france my friends my french is good
enough and i really like france
sure italy but but
i i'm not thinking of moving to poland
and certainly not thinking of moving to
belarus which is not even i wouldn't
even be able to because it's a totally
totally different thing
uh i hope i hope i've been more clear
today
we have a great bonus show for you today
israeli data suggests a fourth covet
shot is unlikely for most people now the
important thing is a fourth one of the
one we have
what about an omicron shot that's a
different story and we're going to talk
about that on today's bonus show number
two the u.s supreme court is going to be
hearing a challenge to race conscious
college admissions these are elements of
affirmative action we're going to talk
about it big big case
and lastly it shouldn't surprise us
after republicans all voted against joe
biden's covet stimulus they took credit
for getting people money and after
voting against
joe biden and democrats infrastructure
bill they are now taking credit for that
infrastructure bill predictable all on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com
to get instant access